beneath the hot skillet surface of the
outback where the baked soil crumbles
like ashes there are treasures to be
found in endless Warren's of burrowing
and hope every hour of every day you can
find people digging and virtually all of
these individuals are like Peter Rowe
and I came here to make a million
dollars so you can make a million
dollars in pity and I came to get my
share that could only be one thing to
find out that's what I came here for to
find that elusive beautiful Jim that
just sort of ban slander date over me
the town of Coober Pedy is home to about
3000 people it was built on opals over
90% of the world's opals come from
Australia and the first ones on this
continent were discovered right here in
1911 finding opal has been turned into
as much of a science as the rock will
allow this team has been digging for a
year and a half since their last
significant payoff they believe they are
only a few feet away from a major find
he said coming now at Brockton sands the
problem is in this town almost everyone
almost everyday believes he is on the
verge of finding a fortune something
like this these opals were all cut out
of the same fist-sized piece of rock and
will sell for at least $300,000 maybe a
lot more but here's the thing 95% of all
opal is colorless worthless
this maze of tunnels did not produce
even a dollars worth of opal one of the
odd benefits of digging so many holes in
search of opals is that some of them can
be converted into homes but it is the
mother lode payoff that is on
everybody's mind with a moral of where
we're sitting now they could be millions
of dollars there is millions of dollars
and there are stones that would knock
your head gems that would be just
astronomical and Muslim never gets seen
never sees a lot of out here where holes
in the ground pass for buildings most
people do not find their fortunes at the
end of this day that started with so
much hope these miners came up empty
again the odds are as long as they keep
questing for opals this will be the
course of their lives for all the hopes
dreams and hard work scratching a living
out of the ground